[Music]
I'm so sorry about this Yoda oh please
we're here to save the life of our
friend that is all
we paid her to help us get in and get
out you think that'd mean oh I'm gonna
help you do it in a way that no one
knows it's happening but no what she
means is I'm gonna shoot people threaten
people's lives
and I know you're probably asking why
would I trust her well that's a good
question the answer is
we used to be in love yeah she was my
girlfriend only she doesn't remember it
because it wasn't her because her dad
threw off a magic clip and she died and
then I lost my temper and nearly
destroyed half the universe
and she came back out of the past there
she is everyone else who died in the
past stayed dead not her why was it the
magic Cliff I don't know got some
freaking infinity stone scientist
and some dumbass dude who met a girl
fell in love
that girl died and then came back a
total dick
[Music]
that is
I'm gonna tell you something
Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians foreign
girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
came back a totaled dick oh please
he left out some important information
but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to find beside my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
foreign
are you ready for One Last Ride
we'll all fly away together
into the forever
beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into nothing
knock it off what I've never noticed how
black your eyes were they were replaced
by my father as a method of torture he
he picked a pretty set
[Music]